Roy Price tiene un trabajo de mucha responsabilidad ya que se encarga
de elegir los programas, el contenido original que Amazon va a hacer.
Y por supuesto que es un espacio muy competido.
Quiero decir, hay tantos programas de TV por ahí,
que Roy no puede solo elegir un programa.
Tiene que encontrar programas que sean realmente geniales.
En otras palabras, tiene que encontrar programas
que estén en el extremo derecho de esta curva.
Esta curva es la distribución por calificación
de alrededor de 2500 programas de televisión en el sitio web IMDB,
y la calificación va de 1 a 10,
y la altura muestra cómo muchos tienen esta calificación.
Si tu programa obtiene una calificación de 9 puntos o más, es un ganador.
Está en el 2 % de programas,
series como "Breaking Bad", "Juego de Tronos", "The Wire"
todos son adictivos,
después de ver una temporada, tu cerebro básicamente es como,
"¿Dónde puedo conseguir más de esos episodios?".
Ese tipo de programa.
En el lado izquierdo, por claridad, en ese extremo,
tienen un programa llamado "Toddlers and Tiaras"
["Rorros y tiaras"] (Risas)
que debería decirles bastante
de lo que pasa en ese extremo de la curva.
Ahora, Roy Price no está preocupado por el extremo izquierdo de la curva,
porque creo que uno tendría que tener un problema mental
para llegar a "Toddlers and Tiaras".
Así que lo que le preocupa es esta protuberancia central aquí,
el bulto de la TV promedio,
esos programas que no son realmente buenos ni malos,
que en realidad no te entusiasman.
Así que necesita asegurarse de que está realmente en el extremo derecho.
La presión es alta,
y por supuesto que es también la primera vez
que Amazon está incluso haciendo algo así,
por lo que Roy Price no quiere correr ningún riesgo.
Quiere diseñar éxito.
Necesita un éxito garantizado
y así lo que hace es hacer una competencia.
Toma un montón de ideas para programas de televisión,
y a partir de esas ideas, con una evaluación,
seleccionan 8 candidatas para programas de televisión,
y hace el primer episodio de cada uno de estos programas
y los pone en línea de forma gratuita para todo el mundo.
Cuando Amazon está dando cosas gratis,
vas a tenerlo, ¿no?
Así millones de espectadores están viendo esos episodios.
Lo que no se dan cuenta es que, mientras ven sus programas,
en realidad, están siendo observados.
Están siendo observados por Roy Price y su equipo,
que graba todo.
Registran cuando alguien presiona Encendido, cuando presiona Pausa,
qué partes se saltan, qué partes ven de nuevo.
Así que recogen millones de puntos de datos,
porque quieren tener esos puntos de datos
para luego decidir qué deberían hacer.
Y, claro, recogen todos los datos,
los analizan a fondo, y emerge una respuesta,
y la respuesta es,
"Amazon debería hacer una comedia sobre 4 senadores republicanos".
Hicieron el programa.
¿Alguien sabe el nombre de la serie?
Público: "Alpha House".
Sí, "Alpha House",
pero parece que no muchos de Uds. lo recuerdan, de hecho,
porque no resultó tan exitoso.
En realidad es solo un programa regular,
literalmente, debido a que el promedio de esta curva aquí está en 7.4,
y "Alfa House" aterrizó en 7.5,
estuvo un poco más arriba de la media,
pero ciertamente no lo que Roy Price y su equipo buscaban.
Mientras tanto, sin embargo, aproximadamente a la vez,
en otra empresa,
otro ejecutivo logró un programa superior utilizando el análisis de datos,
y su nombre es Ted,
Ted Sarandos, el director de contenido de Netflix,
y al igual que Roy, tiene la misión permanente
de encontrar ese gran programa,
y también utiliza datos para hacer eso,
excepto que lo hace un poco diferente.
En lugar de una competición, lo que hizo --y su equipo, por supuesto--
fue mirar todos los datos que ya tenían sobre la audiencia de Netflix,
las calificaciones que dan a sus programas,
las historias de visión, los programas que les gustan y así,
Y utilizaron esos datos para descubrir
todos estos pequeños datos sobre la audiencia:
qué tipo de programa gusta,
qué tipo de productores, de actores.
Y una vez que tuvieron todas estas piezas juntas,
hicieron un salto de fe,
y decidieron licenciar
no una comedia sobre cuatro senadores
sino una serie dramática sobre un solo senador.
¿Saben cuál es?
(Risas)
Sí, "House of Cards", y Netflix, por supuesto, le atinó con ese programa,
al menos por las dos primeras temporadas.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
"House of Cards" logra una calificación de 9.1 en esta curva,
que es exactamente lo que querían que fuera.
La pregunta es, por supuesto, ¿qué ha pasado aquí?
Dos empresas muy competitivas, con inteligencia de datos
se conectan a todos estos millones de puntos de datos,
y funciona muy bien para uno de ellos,
y no funciona para el otro.
¿Por qué?
Como que la lógica nos dice que debería servir siempre.
Quiero decir, si uno recoge millones de datos
para una decisión que vas a tomar,
entonces debería poder tomar una muy buena decisión.
Se tienen 200 años de estadísticas confiables,
que amplificadas con computadoras muy potentes,
lo menos que se puede esperar es buena televisión, ¿no?
Y si el análisis de datos no funciona de esa manera,
lo que realmente da un poco de miedo,
porque vivimos en una época en la que acudimos a los datos más y más
para tomar decisiones de peso que van mucho más allá de la TV.
¿Alguien aquí conoce la empresa Multi-Health Systems?
Nadie. Eso es bueno en realidad.
Multi-Health Systems es una compañía de software
y espero que nadie en esta sala
nunca entre en contacto con ese software,
porque si es así, significa que está en prisión.
(Risas)
Si alguien aquí en EE. UU. está preso, y solicita libertad condicional,
entonces es muy probable que el software de análisis de datos de esa empresa
se utilice para determinar si se le concede.
Así que es el mismo principio que en Amazon y Netflix,
pero en lugar de decidir si un programa de TV va a ser bueno o malo,
se va a decidir si una persona será buena o mala.
La televisión mediocre, 22 minutos, lo que puede ser bastante malo,
pero más años de cárcel, supongo, aún peor.
Y, por desgracia, en realidad hay alguna evidencia de que este análisis de datos,
a pesar de una gran cantidad de datos, no siempre produce resultados óptimos.
Y no se debe a que una empresa como Multi-Health Systems
no sepa qué hacer con los datos.
Incluso las mejores empresas se equivocan.
Sí, incluso Google lo hace mal a veces.
En 2009, Google anunció que era capaz, con el análisis de datos,
de predecir los brotes de la gripe, el tipo desagradable de gripe,
al hacer análisis de datos en las búsquedas en Google.
Y funcionó muy bien, y se hizo un gran revuelo en las noticias,
incluyendo el pináculo del éxito científico:
una publicación en la revista "Nature".
Funcionó muy bien año tras año tras año,
hasta que un año fracasó.
Y nadie podría incluso decir bien por qué.
Simplemente no funciona en ese año,
y por supuesto una vez más fue noticia,
incluyendo ahora una retracción
de una publicación de la revista "Nature".
Así incluso las empresas más versadas en datos como Amazon y Google,
a veces se equivocan.
Y a pesar de todos esos fracasos,
los datos se están moviendo rápidamente en la toma de decisiones en la vida real,
en el lugar de trabajo,
en el cumplimiento de la ley,
en medicina.
Así que mejor deberíamos asegurarnos de que los datos estén sirviendo.
En lo personal, yo mismo he visto esta lucha con los datos,
porque trabajo en genética computacional,
un campo en el que hay mucha gente muy inteligente
que usa cantidades inimaginables de datos para tomar decisiones muy serias,
como decidir sobre un tratamiento de cáncer o el desarrollo de un fármaco.
Con los años, he visto una especie de patrón
o tipo de regla, si se quiere, sobre la diferencia
entre la toma de decisiones acertada con datos
y su fracaso,
y encuentro que vale la pena compartirlo, y es algo así.
Al solucionar un problema complejo,
se hacen esencialmente dos cosas.
La primera es partir el problema en partes
para analizar en profundidad esas partes
y luego, por supuesto, la segunda parte,
juntar todas estas partes de nuevo
para llegar a su conclusión.
Y a veces hay que hacerlo de nuevo,
pero siempre las dos cosas:
desmontar y juntarlas de nuevo.
Y ahora lo crucial es
que el análisis de datos y los datos
son buenos solo para la primera parte.
Los datos y su análisis, sin importar lo poderoso que sea,
solo puede ayudar a partir un problema y comprender sus piezas.
No es adecuado para juntar las piezas de nuevo
y después llegar a una conclusión.
Hay otra herramienta que puede hacerlo, y todos la tenemos,
que es el cerebro.
Si hay una cosa para la que el cerebro es buena,
es para tomar pedazos y unirlos de nuevo,
incluso con información incompleta,
y llegar a una buena conclusión,
especialmente si es el cerebro de un experto.
Y por eso creo que Netflix tuvo tanto éxito,
porque utilizaron datos y cerebros donde deben estar en el proceso.
Usaron datos para comprender primero un montón de piezas sobre su audiencia
que de otro modo no habrían sido capaces de entender con esa profundidad,
pero luego la decisión de tomar esas partes y piezas,
volver a juntarlas y hacer un programa como "House of Cards",
no tuvo nada que ver con datos.
Ted Sarandos y su equipo tomaron la decisión de licenciar ese programa,
lo que también significa, por cierto, tomar
un gran riesgo personal con esa decisión.
Y en Amazon, por el contrario, lo hicieron al revés.
Utilizaron datos todo el proceso para tomar la decisión,
primero cuando hicieron su concurso de ideas de TV,
luego, cuando seleccionan "Alpha House" para hacer su programa.
Por supuesto una decisión muy segura para ellos,
porque siempre podrían apuntar a los datos, y decir:
"Esto es lo que nos dicen los datos".
Pero no se tradujo en los resultados excepcionales que estaban esperando.
Los datos son por supuesto una herramienta
enormemente útil para tomar mejores decisiones,
pero creo que las cosas van mal
cuando los datos empiezan a dirigir las decisiones.
No importa lo poderoso que sean, los datos son solo una herramienta,
y para tener esto en mente, creo que este dispositivo es muy útil.
Muchos de Uds. se...
(Risas)
Antes de que hubiera datos,
este fue el dispositivo de toma de decisiones a usar.
(Risas)
Muchos de Uds. lo conocen.
Este juguete se llama la bola 8 mágica,
y es realmente increíble,
porque si tienes que tomar una decisión, un sí o un no,
todo lo que tienes que hacer es agitar la bola, y se obtiene una respuesta,
"Lo más probable", aquí en esta ventana en tiempo real.
Lo tendré para demostraciones técnicas.
(Risas)
El punto es que he tomado algunas decisiones en mi vida
en las que en retrospectiva, debería haber simplemente escuchado la pelota.
Pero, por supuesto, si uno tiene datos disponibles,
desea reemplazar esto con algo mucho más sofisticado,
como el análisis de datos para llegar a una mejor decisión.
Pero eso no cambia la configuración básica.
Así que la pelota puede ser más y más y más inteligente,
pero yo creo todavía en nosotros para tomar decisiones
si queremos lograr algo extraordinario,
en el extremo derecho de la curva.
Y me parece que un mensaje muy alentador, de hecho,
que incluso frente a enormes cantidades de datos,
aún así vale la pena para tomar decisiones,
ser un experto en lo que se está haciendo
y asumir riesgos.
Porque al final, no son los datos,
es el riesgo que te lleva al extremo derecho de la curva.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)